From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, Joe, we are ready.
Today is Wednesday, May 26, 2011.
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Low History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I am in Austin, Texas with our videographer for the project, Mr. John Bishop.
And we are here to interview Mr. James Oscar Jones for the joint project being conducted by the Library of Congress in the Smithsonian,
and then more particularly Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture, excuse me, the new Civil Rights History project,
the National Civil Rights History series.
This Jones is going to be with you if you think this person down.
Thank you.
As I mentioned before, we turned on the camera today.
I thought we'd start with just to sketch your family history, because I know it will have a lot to do with the course of your life.
And so I'm up here about where you're born, where you came up, parents?
Glad to appear as Ernest Jones and mom, Curtis Jones, that my father born and raised on the farm, that was his life.
That's what he loved to do.
I'm a member of a family of 10 children, six boys and four girls.
And the first five children was born as Routin, because that dad was Routin, and he was killed cutting logs in the wood.
And so that first five were very young when he died, and then my dad Ernest Jones married my mama, and his five more children.
But my dad raised all 10 of us, because it was very, very young when that dad got killed.
And basically what he did was, they were very disciplined, had a seven-grade education, mom had a seven-grade education, but very bright, very brilliant people.
And one of the ambition they had, and they gave us, as we were a little kids, he had two gold for us.
He wanted all of us to be educated, and he wanted to see all 10 of us in heaven.
And so he wanted us to be committed to church, hard work, and school.
So I had the pleasure of going to school all the way through elementary, all the way through high school, and I never missed a day.
He was mean and tough on us going to school.
We had to get up four o'clock in the morning, milk the cows, feed the pigs, and do all of this, walk one mile from the house to the dirt road where the bus came by.
And kissed the bus at 6.45, and you had to do that now, you were sure that was your, and it applied to everybody, the girls and boys the same way.
So we had the fortune of understanding work very early, and going to school very early, and that's kind of what dad shaped.
He said he was when he bought his first acre of land. He was 13 years old.
He paid $1.25, and it took him six months to make that $1.25.
So the farm we grew up on were part of Frank McKinney, which is a German McKinney, which is my mama's side, but then he added to the acreage, and grew us a good, good farm.
Or we farm cotton corn, and then we had, because he couldn't borrow any money from the farmers home administration those days.
He created a large piece of the farm, and we had peach orchards, bearers, and all of that.
And the cash money we made from the seller of the fruit and vegetables is what money he used to farm the cotton corn.
How was the nature of Willisville in those days?
Well, when I was a little boy, there was a lot of folks there.
It never has been an incorporated town, it's just a village.
I would say when I grew up two or three hundred kids, maybe, and what happened is most of the kids grew up with me.
My graded and took off, wanted to draw Dallas, Texas, Houston, Texas, all those places looking for work.
We were the only farm, black farm group in Willisville with a farm.
All the other kids worked on farms, but they were not there.
It was primarily white farmers, and that was a heart, because they weren't allowed to go to school.
They came to school, maybe I have a Thanksgiving, but by March it was time to start telling us all again, they had to come back to work.
So a lot of them didn't have an opportunity to go to school from grade one to high school.
How did your father manage the farm without all that extra help that would have been there in the sense every day of school?
Well, what he did was all of us was big enough to do some of the older sisters and brothers.
But also, he always used, and there were some older kids who dropped out of school and just kind of wondered.
And he would go get those kids and bring them back, and they would work there with us.
And he would pay them at the end of the day, at the end of the week.
They were excited about that, because when they worked on other farms, they didn't own a lot of time.
They would put on the books.
And the problem with that system was they never made enough money, they never worked hard enough to pay off those debts.
You were always, and then dad would have them to come over and set them on to stay fair, was taking place.
And he would say, come on over here, late in the evening, I'll give you a little work so you have a few bucks to go to the fair.
You know, and everybody wanted to go to the fair, but they didn't have it in the minus, so that's how dad helped out.
And then there was gracious to come over and work at our place as well.
We've heard some, tell them about church, and were they active in the end of the week, see?
My mama was very active.
Dad stayed very close to the farm, day in, day out.
But Sunday was a day you couldn't test the farm.
And that was a day you had no choice but to get up and down the dirt road and find the desk going to church.
All day long church, that one share was like the city folk, I ate a clock, I ate a 12 o'clock, no.
You went to church in the morning, and when you got out of that church, you went to another church because my mom had a beautiful singing voice.
And everybody in the neighborhood wanted to come sing, we hop in the back of the truck and go to that place, and then somebody had a five o'clock mean, we go to that church.
So it was church, church, church, church.
Oh yeah, I had plenty of church.
Tell them to turn that there, you know, there's sense of politics and race relations.
My mama, everybody called my mother Vic, matter of fact when she passed away, and they had the name Perdis Jones.
And a lot of folks call her funeral home in Magnolia, said, who is this Perdis Jones?
So they undertake her, say, well, everybody know her as Vic.
And what he said that people from all over the country had left, what did they walk in?
So y'all cannot have that funeral.
Postpone that funeral because we want to come home to that funeral, and that's what the word got out of it was Vic.
So hundreds and hundreds of people came in.
But mama on, she was very active in organizations in WCP, in Magnolia, that was the closest place.
She would go to those meetings.
And when she would come back, she would talk to the kids at church.
Now, we got to do something.
They talked about that meeting, how we can do better, how we, how folks need to learn, how to fix up their own homes, and all that,
and stop depending on outside people.
And then she would, when they would have those meetings, she and her sister would throw people back and they would pick up truck and they would go on.
And it was not a thing where she would go ask parents permission.
She would just get that old truck and just go through and get in the truck, get in this truck and they would go to the meetings.
So the kids, you know, growing up in a rural area, they would go out and jumping back at the truck and go somewhere.
It was not a lot.
And she was, and that was her.
She was just very active all over the place.
And when she learned about what people were doing, she would come back to church and talk to church people about what we need to do is we need to get the men together to do this and women get together because that's the kind of thing she would learn from the end of the SAP meeting.
Do you remember, say, let us think a few things for the 50s and, you know, from Brownby Board to Montgomery to Little Rock, especially Little Rock in where you were.
And this thing has talked a lot about how church people through your life, this one.
The one thing I remember was in the Brown case.
Thurgood Marshall and my dad always had this big old radio, huge radio.
And it was very powerful.
And as a matter of fact, in Williamsville, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, we could pick up St. Louis.
And that's how it would kept up with baseball.
All we had to radio on.
And Mr. Third gear made a statement that was on the radio.
He wanted every Negro in America to stand still that one day at noon because the...
Mr. Jones, we just had a brief pause to check the camera.
You would just start talking about Brown and you were saying important things about your dad and Williamsville, Arkansas, Arkansas.
They were so amazed by that.
And Mr. Third gear put out a radio.
And on that day, 12 noon is the only grocery store that stands still at 12 noon because of the Supreme Court is fixing to make an announcement.
And that announcement and that Supreme Court has got to change this whole nation.
So, daddy, you know, said, and he went to the little school, sweet home where I was going to school.
He went down there and told the teachers about it and said that we need to make sure everybody here what is about to be said.
So, he had that much politics in his hair.
And people got all the radios and really was listening for that announcement.
So, he stayed on the top of stuff the same way he was that same way about farming.
He could not borrow money from the Farmers Home Administration.
But what he would do is that he kept his eyes very close on what white farmers were doing.
And some of the wealthier white farmers would use the spiles and they would break a plow and they had the ability to go and get in mind and get to know it.
And what he did was he would ask those black guys working for those white owners.
Is what they're going to do with that plow?
Oh, nothing. We've already gone and got it.
I want to see if I can get that plow. So, he would go and say, Mr. Walmart, I just want that plow. He can have his bro.
And he would take it up to the little school we went to at vocational school.
And the kids would experiment with welding that back. And so, we would use those plows.
And those were accumulation that he had to pay for as part of his farmers.
He was on top of the farmer as well as the political side of the thing.
And the fact that your father owns his own farm, how much of that matter in two ways? One in relation to other members of the black community locally.
And in relation to maybe how your life unfolded in a sense of how you measured your own possibilities and independence.
The first part on the farm side, what mom and dad had, people who lived on other farms and they had very poor houses.
He knew that if we did any kind of work on those houses, they would get tossed off the farm.
And what he would do, he would have us to go and help them to crack a house and all that kind of stuff.
We would go cut wood and put it on the inside to seal the holes and everything. And that was no cost.
And that was something we, his son, we had to do it.
And when, and if we, I remember the one time my brother under me, he took a quarter of a missile later, he says, you don't do so much.
And we're just so thankful. Here, you all take this quarter, I told you, I don't take no money. You know, dad, I don't want to, this is something he wants us to do for folks.
And we went home and dad would say, did your boy take in the money? I said no sir. I said, just a little bit.
He said, well, how much money did I remember? I don't remember how many. He said, game a quarter, give me that quarter.
And so he took the quarter and we went to church, Sunday. He made just to take that quarter up to the poor pit and put it in an offering.
He could not spit it. And we did that for a lot of elderly people. And so he would just, that kind of carried.
On the, on the other side, I was being kind of trained to do something pretty good, but I didn't see it because dad and mom will go to the school
and have all these talks with the teachers. And what they were talking about, late on, I learned from my older sisters and brothers is that they said, James, dad and mom is there, probably, a year or a smart.
And they are telling those teachers to push you, push you real hard because you got to smile.
And, but I learned that later because I noticed I always have to do everything at school, everything.
We have a little school program. Now we want you to be the MC. We want you to start that group. We want you to be over the agriculture program.
And I had all the assignment. And so when I would come home, I didn't get a chance to go out and play because I had to do all these things.
And they were coming. Now, now, now, James, you got to get all that stuff done. So between feeding the hogs and the chicken and all that. And doing that, but that time is dark.
And I also played basketball and the basketball team. But I didn't see anything in that.
But when I got a little further in school toward the 11th grade, I could see it.
We want you to do some marvelous things, James. And you got your skills, you smart, you do good work in school.
You go in place. That's when they started encouraging me. And then when that happened, I was playing basketball.
And this was a real shock to me. Because we worked hard, but dad didn't give you no money. And we would always ask dad, why do you, other kids come work on a farm?
Why do you pay them, but you don't pay us? He said, that's because I'm saving for hard time. So this was the clearest thing. Well dad is pretty hard.
He said, no, you'll even know what hard time is. You got a place to stay. You got clothes, you're teaching us that you don't know what a hard time is.
And then the guys way across what we call it, Creek, the bus didn't go with us. They were basketball guys.
They would come over to our house and stay with us. And the bus would come down his dirt road. And we were playing in this district tournament.
And dad came up to us and he had like $25 and change and what did I build?
He said, James, take this and your boys got a little money to spend. And he said, and the girls by them ice cream, like nickel and buy the girls and ice cream and all that.
So what we got to the jail is ice cream. And so the word was round, he's rich.
He's rich. He's rich. So a lot of the kids don't call him he rich. If I am, I don't know anybody. I don't see the old.
You saw the same money I saw at that one ball game.
And they went to school as they left. But that was after they left. And in my case, I stayed there.
And my oldest sister and brother went right letters and say, how you doing in school and semi-agreed. And I was sitting in my grade and we were semi-odd dollar.
And back in those days, a dollar man, he was filthy rich.
I'm interested. We'll talk about everything that's going to happen at in Pine Bluff after you get down 61 and especially in 63.
But I'm curious if how much the early 60s were late 50s or early 60s making an impact on you.
Little rock and 57, sitting in Greensboro in 60, all of what happened quickly after that.
The one big favor, not favor, but the one thing that prepared me really well for that is that because Daddy and Mama listened to the radio and they paid attention to that kind of stuff.
And they were really on top of Central High. And I remember one time Mama said to me, she said, son, if you ever put it in that situation, don't turn it down.
You go follow with it. And that was a result of what I didn't realize was that Mama and my aunt and Daddy in the early days they had buses come through a small town.
And even in those days they were the only black folks that were getting that bus on the front seat and taking us with us.
And then that kind of came back to me. I said, oh, we integrated the bus line because when Central High came through it kind of, and over her words, that whenever you get an opportunity to do something for other people, don't be afraid.
Because you didn't come from an afraid. She said, it was dangerous when y'all went to weigh your own kind.
Too many people didn't like that. And y'all been through it and you're seeing it. And you can, when the opportunity comes, don't go to the back of the line.
You go to the head of the line and be brave about it. Now they did talk about that. And when I went to, went off the school, you know, I had all that in my hair.
I wasn't looking for anything. But when I saw, when I got to Pine Bluff in the city, you saw real, real segregation because it was a city in Williamsville, Arkansas, Arkansas.
You're down to war in the woods and when you go to town you would see it. But when I got there, I really saw it.
But I wasn't organized, but I saw it as I went downtown and I saw all the holidays and all those.
I looked at it and I saw, the whole thing I saw black folks were made. So that registered in my mind. When I went back home, I shared with them.
He said, well, son, if you, I'm not going to tell you what to do with this word, my mom will say it to me. If you go somewhere and y'all like, because we would travel sometime in the sport, don't you never go through a back door.
If wise go through the back door, you go through the front door. Now, I heard that from her.
Yeah.
What was your moment ago?
That your family, you know, you were gone and waged your own cotton. Can you tell that story just a little bit about that?
Well, kids who lived on a plantation, they would work hard and you have these 10 and 12 foot long.
And when you picked them which cotton, you were hidden six to five and some guy was really good and hit as much as eight.
But when they brought their bags to the chin, white people didn't let them stay that way, they were on cotton.
So they would bring the bags and drop them. They'd go back. Now, in my case, daddy and mama, aunt, nuh, and uncle Bluford went to the gin.
Now, my mama, dad and uncle and aunt T, were gunpacking black folks.
They would sit right at the gin with them double-barred shotgun and two-shell between their fingers.
And when we got our cotton, come on boys. And they would go up that way, we were our own cotton.
Now, the kids who would bring that cotton to the gin, they couldn't weigh that.
And we would sit there and watch this. Sometimes those bags would be seven to pounds of cotton.
And these guys would ask each other, well, John, what do you think?
Oh, I'll miss you.
Oh, give it take four to one pound. Oh, pretty good old boy. Give them benefit of four to seven pounds.
So that's four to pound. They were taken away from them.
So I was at that and witnessed that. Now, the fun kind of thing was, being clearly and just and all of us,
we felt pretty comfortable because mama, not nuh, was at with those guns.
And so when we weighed our cotton, we were looking quite full.
How could you bring me to weigh that?
You know, everybody in Willisville and the surrounding area believed that if they bother my family,
it was a whole lot of killing when I take place.
They believed that because my brother had been in a real bad racial situation, Troy.
I got his memory of that. He was the only black member that went to a little town called McNeil, Arkansas.
And he got a job working on the railroad road.
He didn't, he wasn't on a train. He was going to hard work putting old spikes on all that to keep it up.
And when he went, wherever they went, and on the way back when they got to McNeil, Arkansas, they told Troy he had to get off the train
because he couldn't, blacks couldn't, well, Negro, one of the black folks, and there's Negro in the middle of the day.
Negroes couldn't ride the train through McNeil, Arkansas's little small town.
And my brother, Troy, wouldn't get off the train.
And just like my parents, he had his weapon.
And well, it was a hard knockdown fight.
You know, he stabbed and cut a whole bunch of white folks, and then they chased him and shot him up pretty bad.
But he got through the wash and all that, and so the white people decided that they were going to come to our house and kill him.
And Mr. Chester Waters is the guy who in Williamsburg had the little store, the both little stores there.
He told the people to don't, don't y'all go over there. Y'all are going to get killed.
And so my dad had some brothers, some cousin, and you had to go down through these walls, this dirt road to get over to the farm.
And about dark at night, he was coming in out of the get-troward.
Man, there was so much shooting and so many people got hit, and I heard him scream, oh, I've been hit.
And what dad had did, and his brothers, when they were shooting people, they went to them and took their guns.
They let them go, but they took all their guns.
And so it was kind of known that the McKinney's wanted to focus on mess wet.
And it was a lot of them. It was a bunch of.
About 68.
No, no, excuse me, how old were you then?
Oh, eight, nine, about a pack.
So really 50s.
Yeah, I went up to Williamsville, Arkansas, Arkansas and go, dad had made the comment, said if they come down here and mess with me, I'm going to kick that ass.
That was the exact word.
So I thought he was talking to me.
And I was at Williamsville, Arkansas, Arkansas like a mile and a half.
So I walked all the way to Williamsville, Arkansas, Arkansas and told his wife, I got a wall back.
But my dad had a sandy kick.
And my wife had a home with told daddy, kick me.
I'll take care of that later because all of it was in the making, preparing for this.
That's an extra one.
Tell me what it was like to impress you when you arrived in Pine Bluff to go to school.
And I'm thinking about, you mentioned already that you saw segregation in the landscape of that city the way you had seen it before.
But also on the campus because that was a very important life institution.
When I got there until Pine Bluff, you know, that was my first big city.
The campus was very pretty. It was really exciting.
And what helped me jumpstart really fast is that school I went to Oak Grove High School was a very good school.
And not in fact they had sent about four guys from that school were professors at Pine Bluff.
And I didn't know that I was before I came along.
And my brother in Milwaukee sent me a letter and said, there is a guy in the vocation school.
You go find him and tell him that child of me, one of the older brother sent you.
He was a Hainan, a Dr. Hainan. And I went there and I walked into his office.
He looked up and he said, I don't know your name, but you show one of them Jones.
From Ralston, Willis Meal. And he recognized, oh yeah, you look just like Ernest Jones.
And I started talking and then he really was telling me all about the school and walked around and took me all over the campus and said,
this is one of my boys. Ernest Jones boys. Them boys are sweet kind.
I mean, he really just painted his beautiful picture. They are smart.
And I want all the professors to keep their eyes on him. He's a good student.
Don't be putting him over in social status. He's a good man, algebra.
He came from a high school that had all of that. Because when the guy asked me, he said,
when God told me that you might need to take preliminary courses, he said, you from a small town.
I said, yeah. He said, what did you have in high school? I said, I had algebra.
I had trick and geometry. I had physics. I had biology, chemistry.
He said, man, what got a school that you go to as I had a school that was very good school.
And matter of fact, the principal imported. He handpicked teachers from all around to come and at that school.
Was it a good fight?
No, it was a school, but it was there were four schools in Arkansas.
And there was built way back in the 1931 by the Ohio.
I think they were, they were the, it's a group out of New York somewhere built the school way back.
Because I know our 1929. And the school was built.
And they had vision of folks coming because the school was built with Dometaurus.
So these teachers came from other place and they lived right down campus.
I think the Quakers are Quakers of. And there was two all black school districts.
Mine was one of them. And the other one was Arkansas City where I opened the magazine.
Johnson Man came out of it. So we had, unlike a lot of other school, we had books because we could float bonds.
And we had the books not because a lot of the white school give out all books to the black schools.
But no, we had good books and we had good teachers and things like that. So I had a good start.
You're describing a personal history that isn't very typical for folks in that time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was good.
Between, I'm sorry.
So when I got to Pine Bluff, I was very comfortable and had met somebody that had been in Austin and then he took my round.
And then he introduced me to Dr. Marshall.
And Dr. Marshall was a professor on campus and he had another little house right by his house.
And he asked me, he said, well, you want to live in a Dometaurus?
Well, I got to live somewhere. And Dr. Hain said, put him in your house over there.
And you will take a liking to this young man.
And so we started talking and he said, you sure know a lot to be a country boy.
He said, he's a country kid because they don't know nothing.
And we'd take the city kids and know everything.
And so we just started talking.
And then he was the one told me, he said, there's some folks in Lurak that's trying to get a civil rights thing started.
And they want to fill in the Smith.
And they didn't know what to look at because all those kids were city kids and their parents said no.
And they were going to get put out of school and all that.
And he said, I want you to, I like to meet those guys.
And that's when Worth Long, it's not a very Worth Long.
And when Worth Long came down and Worth Long and Bill Hansen.
And I hadn't met Worth a little bit late on my hand.
And so a few days later they rolled cream and started talking.
And so Bill Hansen said, dang man, you've already done what we tried to do.
Now it's your hometown.
And then when I said, well, that's how I was raised.
He said, man, this would be a piece of cake for you.
But then they, that wasn't when they were trying to get it started.
But they said that they were working in the Lurak and do some things.
But when we come back to Pinebluff, we need to sit down and talk because this is a college town.
And there's a lot of segregation here.
And I hear you guys are down here.
They all got all these McDonald's and all of this.
And the black people can't go to.
And this city is driven by the university here.
So that's, and that's how I met them.
And remember more specifically about this group of folks, Worth Long and Hanson,
and one black, one white, they're SNCC people.
You just thought at first you might have a SNCC maybe?
When, when we met, Worth Long talked about he had been involved in labor and union groups a lot.
When Bill Hansen talked, he talked about he had been involved in city and and things like that.
And, but the first thing Bill Hansen said is we need to organize some student to challenge.
They had already been around and solved the McDonald's.
I didn't know what the McDonald's and all that was.
Even though it was right down the street.
But Bill Hansen's take was, I'm a white boy and I don't need to be leaving.
And then that's what he said.
But we need a black person and you've already done all this stuff.
And he said, if you went into one of the white restaurants and was arrested, what would your parents say?
They would come up here and they would come to the jail house and they would say, James, is this what you want to do?
And if I say yes, he said, we're doing whatever you need, I should support you and they would go back home.
He said, really?
They wouldn't ask him that.
I said because they talked to me, law the fond of doing things about this kind of stuff, if you get involved and stuff and they talk about, don't you ever go through white doors, back doors, you go through the front of the front door and white people go, you go through it too.
He said, whoa, man, you're mama's civil right?
Well, I guess not because I don't know what to do.
The whole lot to do, but I did tell them, I shared with them how mom and him wrote the bus and he said, yeah, that's civil rights stuff.
I said, I didn't know what, but that just, to me, that's how they were.
And I remember a Brian Warmac was the, we considered it a rich white man in what it's real.
And as we got involved, as I got involved, he was talking to mom about, you need to go get that boy and he up there doing all this and the black girl and that way you need to be and not run around.
So, mama got the word and I wasn't holding this happen.
They said, mama, wet and jumped in the car with him, made him take her out to a wall, do it about some clothes with me.
And told him, I really ought to make you take these clothes and buy them for love.
And I was supposed to say, and Mr. Warmack was a big white guy.
He said, it was freezing cold, he was wet, he was so wet, cause he knew mama had that pistol of purse.
But, no, no, I told him, no, no, my mama would do that.
And he said, because in Lurot, that was the issue.
Everybody was afraid that they would take them out of school and do all this and that's why they couldn't get that started.
Did you, early on, do you have any instinct that what might actually end up being a problem would did end up being one problem?
Would emerge, namely, that the folks that need to get the college, would, that your president would...
You know, I didn't think that side at all.
You know, I went and looked at the hotel that was segregated and I went down there, not myself.
The first time, just walking out.
And when I came back, when they started talking about, we need to protest these places.
I said, let me go talk to some student.
And when I talk to them, I told them what my parents lack.
But I also said, now, if your parents is going to come up here and jump on you for doing it, don't go.
And then, Mr. Dr....
Her husband was a principal at a high school.
And he told me, I went in that with him.
He said, now I got some young high school student in my school, Towns Townsend Park High School.
The big high school there for most of the black were Merrill High, but this school was kind of getting started.
He said, these kids, when you tell them how to do it, they need to get involved with a guy like you.
He said, they're smart, but they want to be thugs.
He said, they're real brave, and they want to be thugs.
He said, but I think if they were around, you would change them.
I said, you think so?
And so I met with them and talked to them about, you know, my parents, what that was like.
And they liked that. I said, now look, but now what we're talking about is going here.
And it may be very violent, but we're going to be a non-violent group.
So all the boys are, oh, I don't know.
No, no.
It's going to be some fight.
And, oh, no, no.
I mean, they hit you in the face and knock you down.
You just going to fall and get up.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
But, you know, so why do you think that would be the idea of the non-violent group?
Well, the way I looked at it was if you can be non-violent, the white people would be very
happy to beat you down.
They would be very happy doing that to you.
But I felt though that in spite of that, you could overcome it over time period.
And I felt that if I would be now and the other kids was scared and afraid of it, I think eventually they will come around.
I told my kids, I'll tell them how they did.
And I just, and I think what helped me is I wasn't scared.
I wasn't scared.
I, my knowledge wasn't good enough to feel that I definitely could win doing it right there.
But I felt that I could see in white people faces that it was working because I saw a young white girl and young white boys come up and would hit me and stuff and run.
And when I was looking at them, I saw them crying.
I saw them crying, but they wouldn't focus to see them.
But I saw them.
I said, you know, they're doing something they don't want to be doing.
And I saw that.
And when I told, like, Grin is that, he said, for real, I said, yeah, you know, they were told to come up and hit us.
But that wasn't in their heart.
And I saw it.
I saw that wake up.
We can do this.
The end of the first day, February 163, and the war was for you.
How did it feel at the end of that day?
That was a little scary because we sent the first day we went to war work.
We tried to go there.
It was locked.
We couldn't get in.
It was closed.
We were invasion of something.
And then, what's the name?
Diane Nash.
Diane Nash came.
It was in town.
Diane Nash.
What's Diane Nash last name?
I understand she's still going.
Strong.
Diane Nash.
Anyway, she was an extremely light-skinned black girl.
She went down to war with us and went in and eat because they thought she was white.
And when she came back, she said, no, that's open.
And when we went in, she said, go in at 11 o'clock, just for some reason.
I think that was the time.
I guess a lot of people are going to be in there.
We pound in there.
And it was a massacre because Diane Nash had been through the freedom riots and all that stuff.
And her theory, her strategy was that if there were a lot of people in there, it wouldn't hurt very well because it would be enough room.
And then she said that they start hitting you, fall to the floor.
And when you fall to the floor, to do all this, fall toward what the people were.
So when we did that, all the white folks in there was also on the floor.
So you died off of that.
They tried to get up.
You scooped a little bit from the fall.
So it was kind of fun and a little bit scary, you know.
That's how you went.
Dr. Lawrence A. Davis Sr, before too many days.
Oh, that's...
Is it me with you?
Yeah.
That one were two things because we had a pretty good crowd, but that was short-leaf because Dr. Lawrence A. Davis Sr called us in.
And then half of the parents came to Pinebluff, too.
And they were snatching all of them, kids.
I think when they finished with Dr. Lawrence A. Davis Sr and the parents, three or four of us made them left.
I know I was there.
Nash.
I think, you see.
Joanne State, the girl Joanne.
And now, as a fact, Joanne is a professor at Pinebluff at college.
And I think she just retired.
She stayed...
Who else?
There was this tall guy from Texarkana, AR/TX.
He stayed on.
He was about four of us.
And then we all went to see the president, and he was pretty point blank.
He told us the very next day anybody who went downtown was suspended.
Now, the interesting thing about that now, that was kind of different.
It was only about four or five of us who said, what's going?
But when we went the next time, there were about 12 or 15 folks in the suspension.
But they didn't come the first time.
So it's kind of gruel of it now.
And he put us all out.
How'd you make your decision to take that hit, take the explosion?
Well, you've said a lot already.
It creates a context for that.
But that's still, that must have been not a music day.
But in my case, in my case, folks, everybody asked me, what are your parents think?
I said, my parents support what I'm doing.
And the tall guy from Texarkana, AR/TX, he called his parents and took them for them.
They kind of let them along.
This other guy, Nash, he was from Pineblum.
He stayed there.
And that was kind of like the voice of encouragement.
And they were sitting there and listening to me.
And what if we get hurt?
I said, we are going to get hurt.
But we, you know, we are like, this is like a war.
And we're worth the attack, but there was no jail stuff there.
And I said, eventually, we're going to have to go to jail.
We continue to do this.
So there was a little bit of a shrapnel of the jail.
And then we went back there two or three times, shut out.
The most violent, I thought the most violent was the one who went to Magnolia, Arkansas.
I thought that was it.
I think that crowd really meant to hurt us.
And I think what helped us was their owner locked the door, locked us in and turned that gas on.
And again, awesome.
But I think if we had not been locked in, their audience I saw on the outside, they really had weapons and backs back.
And I think they would have heard us real bad.
Can you scrub down moment a little bit more when you turn that head over to the assembly, turn the gas on?
When we were in there, the kids that was working in there, they left.
And we were still at the counter, waiting to be served.
And they locked the doors.
Now, the gas was not the natural gas.
It was what kind of gas was that?
That fog, they turned that fog off and it burns you.
And it gets in your eyes and shut your breath and off.
What is that gas called?
That's your gas?
Yeah, yeah, that's kind of a cat gas.
Now, what helped me with that was my brother Troy was in Houston.
He had talked around at home about that gas because police would shoot it sometime.
And he said, if the way you found that is that water helps you die to make sure you have some water.
And if you're in a building, come over, put your head in the water, water the towel, and he told me that.
And so when they shot that gas, I went to the sink, turned them sink, the water was still on.
And I said, everybody get into water.
We all went into the water.
And I guess somebody would close back on the water, get cut off.
We were surviving pretty good.
But that was, and that was just burned.
So it was, it was, I guess the owner, because it was a shooting.
And then when they came through the back, sprayed and then locked down.
And we was in there.
Yeah, that's how that came about.
But fortunately for us, I heard about that.
And we had a little water.
That calm people down a little bit.
One of the key things in a lot of this kind of moments was the tensions that are inevitable.
And that just couldn't be avoided in those moments of life.
So for example, talk about cancer data.
His pressure is trying to, well, I guess he has a set of motives.
Yeah.
Typically understood to be the legislature was in session.
Right.
And make sure that the water, the water, cut back, sharp the cold.
Black clergy, the tradition, and the way CPL eats.
The black business community, the extended.
People have different interests and motives.
Can you talk about how the black community came down on us very hard.
There were two black business people that supported us.
The entire black neighborhood, one of those who had run out of town.
The Mr. Brown was the funeral home guy.
He was all alone and one.
And the white population got very upset with him because he was wealthy.
And he said to us, this thing I get out of hand, but I'm going to just say this part right here.
If y'all end up in jail, don't worry about it.
I'll bond everybody out of jail.
And that's all he said to us.
Mr. Brown, the funeral home man.
And his son, he was an older guy.
And his son was about to take over.
And he said, Dad, you're sure you want to do this?
His dad said to him, son, if you don't want to do it, get out.
I'm going to do it.
And his son came back and said, I'll handle for you, Dad.
The other person was Dr.
Dr.
That was one, he was about a dentist.
Very, very well known dentist.
And of the medical community, he was only one.
And he came that evening after his over with.
And he asked, was anybody hurt?
If anybody get hit in the mouth, they'll worry about it.
I'll take care of it at no cost.
So those two were the only two business people.
Now, when we went down, when you were going to go to us,
back down there was a couple of business there.
There was a little club there and something else.
Now those folks told us not to walk all that side.
We got to go on the other side and we're going to the side.
Walk over that.
These are black business.
Get off the side.
So that, now, one thing that came to our rescue, I think,
is there's this guy named Reverend B.E. Allen.
He was the pastor of a large Methodist church.
And I think Reverend B.E. Allen may have been from New York or somewhere
about, you know, how the Methodist church transversion.
And we didn't know who he was.
There, come this guy, this blue suit.
And we were getting ready to go to.
I think we were fixing to go to.
Holiday Inn maybe.
Because that's where we got the rest of the fresh and rest.
And this guy shows up first in the guy, nice blue suit.
And we were standing at this, at this hall there.
And this guy walks up and says, you know, these are students here to get an education.
Their parents worked hard and gave them money to come up here to go to school.
They got money coming to your place and pay for that meal.
And we'd all sit there.
We had no idea who this guy was.
And so in this manager, whatever, he came out and said, who are you?
That's when he said, I'm Reverend B.E. Allen.
The passive would have this church.
He said, yes sir.
You know, the United Methodist church know you involved with this.
He's not involved with nothing.
I think these are our future.
You need to get off the premises.
Don't you go on a jail?
He said, you have to stand on the premises, just stand in here and have an conversation.
Just take me with you.
I got the impression we all got excited.
But it looked like it was something about him being a Methodist kind of calm those folks away.
And then that's when he turned around and said, do y'all have meeting to get together?
And they're asking, yes, they're saying, my church door is open.
Day or night.
So who's that?
There's someone saying, thank you.
And so we left and went to church and kind of talked about what may happen.
This might be a going to jail thing because this guy had police standing back as if they were going to arrest us.
So we went to church and thought we came the next day.
And the next day we came, that's when them kids, from towns, the thugs were going to be thugs.
And this year, what up?
It was about six, seven of them.
Whoa.
I said, I walked on and talked to them and said, now you know, this is an unbounded outpost.
We go on which...
And then that was...
It's really...
This guy had this real dark skinned guy.
All these guys had nickname.
One guy was Pope-Pope, Pope-Pope-Mow, hot dogs.
All these nicknames.
It took me a long time to try to figure out the real name.
And he was supposed to be in the real bad though.
He would fight in a minute.
He said, now, Bill Hansen and Worth Long and all that.
Now we're going in.
We're going down which one this one.
He said, when it's all over with and saying, I'm cool, we'll get our punches in there.
It's what you'll be.
We know how to get back.
It might be six months later.
I said, don't break that.
Why would we do that?
We're going down which...
They ain't going to be no fighting.
Those talk back, we're going with it.
And so they...
They are.
They did that.
And that was the first arrest.
Some of the...
Some of the falls...
Okay.
We're back on.
I just didn't want to cry over the next few days.
Oh, okay.
Some of the things happen pretty close in time that are both very significant.
One is...
The first ever...
Very modest, but the first ever successful integrations at a restaurant table in Pine Blanc, March.
But also pretty quickly, that's when the arrests are going to start.
Maybe a lot of people on jail by the end of March.
Because at least problems switch captive.
And as you were just saying, you know, you get to a point where you think, yeah, we might now be heading towards arrests.
When that moment arrived,
I wonder how you made your calculation because of what...
The implications of jail,
Jails and those places in those lines.
I think that was a fear, a real fear moment.
That's that, that, because when we had to be, you know, that, but that all that was outside.
I think when we talked about the hotel, they'll take us down.
I think the college people in the crowd was real nervous.
But some young guys, they had bid the jail.
If they were kind of like an asset, they said, oh man, it ain't no big thing.
They just, it's just going to be crowd and nasty up in there.
And I said, what y'all thought?
Oh, we've been there before.
So what people started engaging in Alabama.
But I think that kind of calmed people nervous a little bit.
Just those younger guys had been there.
And then when Mr. Coleman came by,
and he didn't go to jail, but he was standing across the street.
And I think when people looked around and saw the faces,
even though they were the long, distant way,
kind of made you feel a little bit,
that way we kind of got a little support.
But what going to jail, dear, was amazing to me,
is that is when the jail thing is when the old black people came out.
And they had a meeting at Reverend B.E. Allen Church.
There wasn't no college student and then like that.
But I was told that church was packed.
And they were talking about having a bond,
that's how I know all that.
And Mr. Brown and they said, no, I'll go work.
And they tell me that some of the little ladies had low roles of money
in that brawl and some had it in the shoes,
bringing that little money to bell us out.
And I think when that church group,
that old population,
I think that shook the whole city
because after that we saw a lot more yelling and cursing
and white people start throwing objects,
but they weren't that close to us.
You know, you're the niggas, you're the niggas.
I'm throwing at us. That was a big chain.
At first, they was knocking you down.
So we were like, oh, I think that's going to have some impact here.
Because the old people didn't come out and barked
but they would come to that church.
And then they started doing things like going to the jail house,
asking people to jail how,
can we bring the kids some food?
And at first they said no.
And I don't know who changed that by no Reverend B.E. Allen and some members.
And when they brought the food down there,
they let us out on this big old,
that bad park where when they lock you up,
they hold it up, they hold it and say up before they send you to
it, we're in a back where you know,
the tight bars.
And those people brought, they let us,
they actually let us eat.
You know, they had only big old fat chiefs
and they're like they got a kill some matter
but they let them bring their food in.
And I think that calmed people because from that point on,
every time we go back,
we'll see a few more people coming and stuff like that.
And then the one thing happened,
a little scary, is on campus,
somebody had said that if we don't stop demonstrating the football team,
this sports team, we're going to lose,
this thing going to take all that money.
I think that was a scare tactic.
But man, we,
when we were bunded out of jail,
there were a lot of girls and things from all pinebluff were coming to see ya.
Man, I'm big old football players came down after,
she had them folks out of way and threading the bust out of school
and that was scary.
Because I think some of them guys did take that serious.
There y'all go back and if I lose my sky,
I'm a key of myself.
So that, that, that, that was...
That wasn't just no sports, it was no scholarship.
Right.
So that was kind of scary.
That was pretty scary of that.
What was the, what was the,
how did your case ever get?
What was the resolution of the illegal case in a narrow legal side?
Well, the attorney for us was,
was like, I didn't even, right then, pinebluff.
Why did you do that?
The wilder brand took the big stuff,
now everything.
It was a, it was a,
it was a young,
real small black guy,
had a law, a law firm.
And everybody said,
no, no, he's not gone,
he's not gone to participate.
He really got a good law firm.
But I think, way later,
I think maybe Bill Clinton,
somebody appointed him to be a,
a federal judge.
He had a little bit of guy.
And, and he walked into church.
That's a little son after little church.
We had all got out and there's just,
tons of people came.
Oh, he just loved you.
Yeah, all right.
And he came in there and he just walked in
and told Reverend B.E. Allen,
I'll handle a case.
And just left.
Just like that.
And,
I'm not sure what happened to that case.
Because I don't remember going to court.
I don't know if it was thrown out of what.
Because the big stuff,
that my man with Allen,
he was the whole,
a discrimination,
civil rights rights.
And he had a big,
just a big, big, big case.
And he was appealing to his to the federal level.
So it,
it kind of started coming down.
And,
so we went,
we went to
Woolworth again.
And what they had done,
I guess that told all the white people
don't come in at a certain time.
So we went out and eat.
And,
we went back to the hotel.
And the guy told us,
it was full.
And,
they didn't tell me,
but I was told later that,
they told some people that,
they told me to keep my doors open.
And,
they keep me off the lawsuit.
they keep white people,
because the white people get mad,
they go and destroy my hotel and all that kind of stuff.
He said,
could you tell your people come down here after dark?
At night.
So,
I don't know if that happened,
but I know,
I'm glad we had a little thing,
and they let us use a rope.
I never,
I never did want that.
I didn't go that too,
I just spent the night.
So, it, it, it, it settled a bit.
Yeah.
You ever want to make a transition of a sort towards,
towards what will be a decision to take a photo of a SNCC?
And,
hopefully they didn't,
and also,
before that,
did you ever circle back around?
If not,
any kind of closing conversation,
or meet again,
in some later sense with,
Chancellor Davis?
No, no.
We, we were,
bad.
We couldn't even,
yeah, we couldn't even go on campus,
or not that.
No.
Is it later or not?
No, no.
So, there were,
that first wave of suspension.
Now, there were three or four kids who were suspended,
and stayed with us a while.
Now, they went back to school,
and you're late.
Oh, yeah.
That was a condition.
But, you know,
I, I never,
to go back,
my wife was suspended,
she didn't, she didn't go back.
What do you mean?
I got married,
May 16, 1964.
Okay.
Yeah.
She, she wasn't in the arrest group,
but she was with us when we went to,
the very first one,
Woolworth,
and she,
and we went,
where else do we go?
Who was arrested in the,
at the hotel,
because she didn't,
she didn't get arrested.
But she, she, she was in the group of,
of that first group,
my wife was,
and a homegirl of her,
but, uh,
now she never,
to go back,
to go in, never went back.
It was about seven or eight of state,
state to go.
Yeah.
Let me ask you about something that's going to be,
come very, very important in the,
the SNCC Arkansas story,
and space in a few years,
but in this,
in this early phase,
60,
spring,
63,
you need more in a little ways.
You mentioned that you,
you,
you won't become your wife.
Mm-hmm.
Uh,
you'll handsome on me,
mm-hmm.
Woman who will become a,
yeah, girl.
Followed this conversation.
Mm-hmm.
Um,
and so, two things I'm interested in.
One is,
what it's like to be with other people,
in such relatively intense circumstances,
and you reflect about what that's called,
first,
uh,
well, in the road ahead.
Okay.
This is John's, I want to ask about,
a couple of things,
thinking about,
being together with other people
doing this intense work.
Mm-hmm.
One is, uh,
your reflections and perspective on,
on being with people in such intense circumstances,
the relationships,
the human dynamics of that kind of experience,
and also the interracial aspect of that,
and your specific circumstances,
then,
fine-blocks,
and then,
SNCC Arkansas,
and what will come down.
Mm-hmm.
The, um,
the environment,
the interracial,
environment,
made everything more difficult,
on the white side,
and the black side.
On, on the black side,
there was a lot of growing,
resentment,
toward whites,
being involved,
because they were being perceived as,
as the lead part,
not,
not black folks themselves.
Though that was not the case,
but that's what they saw,
and they saw a lot of that,
through Bill Hansen.
Um,
when we would go to the,
um,
uh,
meetings,
like we have meetings,
mass meetings,
and trying to recruit people
in the neighborhood,
or trying to get something started.
We specifically,
made an effort for me to,
lunch it,
because,
when the whites would,
um, try and launch it,
it would just kind of die there,
no response,
and,
and it always would be a thing
where the black folks want to hear,
my asses of that,
so that,
that really stole,
meetings,
and efforts to strategize,
real bad.
On the,
uh, racial,
on the racial side,
I think,
um,
that was a,
hard,
core resentment,
in the case of,
uh, Bill
and Ruthie,
uh,
and the racial marriage,
right then,
Lurac,
uh, right then,
I can say,
that was just,
I know enough.
And,
and I think when,
thing would get in the look
quite sometime,
when whites would see that,
it would flare back up.
Well, that's what it's all about,
you know,
it's all,
that was, uh,
that was really what generated the,
what generated the,
the thinking is that,
we got to,
officially made Jim Jones,
the head of this,
to get rid of that,
because that just too much of,
too much,
because when we were,
when we were going to protest,
it was so much focus on the whites,
you really couldn't get,
kind of,
through to talk about what we're trying to do,
uh,
that attitude,
was what the way,
boy, they don't need to go,
they don't problem with them going to,
a holly in the state,
they just need to make trouble,
that's how they perceive that.
So, that made it,
more difficult.
And when,
I took charge of it,
I told Bill,
you stayed to office
and coordinated some stuff,
let us run this thing.
And,
and that made it,
the crowd was,
a lot more comfortable.
And I think,
we were growing at numbers,
when, when,
when that move was made as well.
When you needed to shift into these,
more prominent,
consistently prominent roles,
because obviously,
the prominent roles fall away long,
but,
and,
uh,
project director title,
shifted to you,
64.
How did Hanson,
and,
were there implications for your relationship,
your working relationship,
your personal relationship?
How did it go?
No, no,
that, that,
that stayed pretty good.
But,
but, um,
Hanson was a very aggressive,
very aggressive person.
And we,
and I had to really
shut him down,
a lot of time in situation.
I said,
now,
there are some places
we need to target,
like the voter registration stuff.
And,
and I made a Pacific point,
fire city,
you know,
West Helena, Arkansas,
Forrest City,
um,
Marianna, Arkansas,
those,
those are hard,
cold, conservative,
8-area,
cause,
all that part of Arkansas is where all of them
big plantation wide.
And,
and I said,
and we got to be careful,
because,
I think they are some of them,
they called them,
I'm,
I'm good ol' boys.
See me and you, I think the shot gonna be fired at you.
And he didn't want to do none of that, but me and Worth Long, all of us are now, I'm going.
You know, that comes a time when we plan to see and got things going.
You know, and we got a little group together.
That's okay.
But for you to come out, you know, in a league capacity over there, that's too dangerous.
You're in danger in two minute people.
And he was very, he didn't want to do that because, though he didn't say it, never would admit it.
He liked that lamb like.
He liked it.
He liked it, but he swayed it.
Yes you do.
You love, read your name.
You love getting hit in there yet.
And then rubbed to a caramel and showed a blood on you.
They ain't what it's about.
And I knew when we went to those places, they were going to respond to the car my skin.
Because it was all the whites who they knew in those neighborhoods were folks they didn't like.
We don't need you to add to it.
And when we, now, when I got the first place, I went to, was, uh, Forrest City.
Now, the Forrest City surprised me to respond kind of quickly.
And I think it had to do with, uh, Miss Clay, she on the funeral home,
and she, and she had a big old house and she said, you know, come and take that house, you can stay there.
And then she had a sister cousin who was a principal.
And, and I think she had that, the profession of folks around her.
And, and when we went, and when we went to a house and she called them all over, then we told them,
I said, no, we ain't trying to integrate, uh, something head and Forrest City.
But it's such a huge base.
That part of Arkansas is 90% black.
And the voting over here is zero.
And, and so I think that issue was a little easier than cracking the, the restaurants and, and going to jail.
But, uh, no, no, that were, that were, that's the mission there.
And, and I think the issue had to do with, uh, uh,
Bill didn't want to relinquish his role.
But we kind of got through it, but that was, we had to get trouble.
And now, stay here.
We had to do it that way.
I asked more about the voting work and registration work and, and other parts of the program in the Delta.
But when we first asked, how did you, did you go Atlanta occasionally?
Did folks come from Atlanta from SNCC to, how, how did the relationship with the national folks work out?
Most of the, most of us was, uh, I would take trips down there and, and they would have those, we call, uh,
coordinating, uh, meeting.
And that's where all the different states that was involved, hell, you snick people, we would come there and,
and we would exchange thoughts and ideas.
What are you doing here? How did, how do you overcome that and, and, and, and a lot of that?
So, I got a good feel, good feel for it.
But, uh, one of the things that I felt differently about was,
I thought I had a better feel for people that I can solve.
And that, because I had a farm background, a lot of the folks back in those days, somewhere where farm connected.
And when I got to Atlanta and we'll go down there, all of them boys were big city boys.
And they were just be sitting up, articulating and, and, and, uh, in order to save, we're going to go, uh,
down the road to a store.
Take them three hours again, because they had these educated kids and, there was articulating what they know and,
all the big words, I just be sitting there, saying, what are they, what, what are y'all doing?
It, it was, I saw a lot of, showing off that, education, and not a good feel for the neighborhood.
That, that never was a public. And when they, uh, and then when they were asked,
meaning to, they comment, what I would talk very specific about, the level of folks I'm dealing with and,
what the issue is that and, and then I don't think that's going to happen until blah, blah, blah, blah.
And so, old James Forman told me one time, he said, he said, Joan, what you are doing is a direct,
a direct connection to the community.
But that, that's a wonderful thing. And he said, and he asked me, he said, do you want, uh, do you want us to send some people?
And I said, well, not really. But I tell you what I would like to do.
There is, you got a group down there, that's a great singing group.
Send that group up here and, and to one of those meetings I have, because I have a lot of people,
and they church folk, they'll love that. And I said, and, and less slowly graduate.
But those guys, you know, when they came and saw that big crowd, all they want to do was sing.
And have a good time and we'll go back.
But, uh, but what I was doing was, uh, asking people, uh, uh, put their shoes on and let's go knock on some doors and try to get people to vote.
And, and then I said, also, uh, I told Miss Clay, Miss Clay, we need some, a couple of folks to run for something.
But they need to be educated, they need to be highly respected.
And then she told me that, um, this guy that was, they had a little, uh, plan in far as city.
I think it'd be up in a comment factor. He said, well, that guy over there, he, he been promoted managed.
That was a less run-in. And, and we did. And, but it, it wasn't like the mayor, but it was a position and he wanted.
And, and folks that I never thought I was going to happen. I said, well, you do have to make an effort to make it happen.
And he went on and did real well. And I said, and that's what, that's kind of stuff we need to do as well as, um, you know, we don't have to, we don't have to go into a white restaurant.
He, so if somebody do want to do that, you know, uh, they can.
Yeah, you know, so, uh, so that, that, that's the, that's the direction I went.
The SNCC program seemed to have those three big thrust public combinations where you could do that.
Then, uh, the whole voter registration and starting to run people in electoral campaigns.
And, um, education too. You talk about schools questions.
I've read that, uh, I've seen the numbers for what the SNCC program accomplished in short order.
I mean, pretty darn short order. 24 months. Less than that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
More people have signed up to spite poll tax system.
A lot of candidates get into racism. Right. Right. There's the 66 governors race outcome, which is the biggest thing because of the black voters.
And, um, we're enrolled. Okay. We're back on after a short break for equipment.
Mr. Jones, we were, we were starting to talk about the program.
You see, put in the work out there and the voting work, getting people into the races and coming just turn over to you.
Um, in some cases, folks fail short in vision because there were individuals who public accommodation was all they had in that year.
And, you know, once you integrate, uh, uh, desegregate and all the restaurants has opened their doors.
And you can go in the, uh, uh, go in the town and get your room.
To me, that's, that's finished.
But we have some folks who, you know, look long distance. Let's go, let's go to Chicago and protest.
That's an example of, because that was the only spoke with the hat.
And, and those are the folks, uh, that's what I can say. I can say, no, you know, that, that's where we need to.
This population need to, you know, access voting and start running candidates.
You know, and that was a new, new piece to it.
Uh, but some folks were stuck. I mean, they were stuck and couldn't get off that.
Yeah. Yeah.
You describe a, your experience across a, a, uh, a representative week doing voter registration work in the Delta,
a fall in 63, 60 early, 60 or what happens to you in that week?
And you could see in what's it like and how's it feel when my approach to it is in every community,
almost every community, there is that woman.
In most cases, it, it was women.
And, uh, I learned that from, and later they was dearer and goo, this dearer.
And she said, young man, when you go into a neighborhood,
um, for the first time, if there's a black barbershop there, go in there.
That's okay. And you press, as far as Pacific type people,
I'm gonna come for somebody that's, um, is interested in politics or,
know some good people that could run for office or they have a lot of influence.
She said, those guys have been me and them barbershop.
I know that stuff. So when I went to foreign city, I took that advice.
And, uh, I pulled up and there was about four or five guys out there.
I think these are working people on the break.
And I said, I'm introducing myself.
And I didn't say I were SNCC.
I said, I'm part of a program and we're trying to encourage, uh,
black folks to vote more on, and, and even better than that,
we would like to see more black folks run for office.
And when I said that, the first thing came with, like all three of them said the same thing.
You need to go talk to Mrs. Clay.
I said, now who's Mrs. Clay? She owns a funeral home.
The husband died, but she, she, she made even bigger funeral home.
That's who you need to talk to.
And, uh, so I have another vote wagon.
I said, how do I get them? Oh, come on. Follow me.
They were like, they actually had to do something to her.
And she was, she was ran, she ran to go. She said,
young man, I'm just glad to see you. It's long overdue.
She was all excited. And, uh, she said, I told my sister,
I said, what just says, she said, she's a principal of that.
And just the two of us talk all the time.
She don't have more than that.
And, uh, and she said, how you want to do that?
I said, uh, I said, first of all, I, I need to place a stay.
I probably need to stay two, three days. She said, see the house right there?
See the house right there? See the house right there?
See the house right there? Yeah. All of my house.
Which one you want?
I'm sad. That's at least all asleep.
And, uh, man, she was then fixing the paper and her sister came over.
And she said, told about this preacher.
He said, he's a very aggressive preacher, but he by himself went over there.
And I said, well, we need to have a meeting.
And those two women said, we'll do the calling.
You're just going to that. I don't know who all they called.
But they had a church pact that night.
And that's when this guy's name came up. He was there.
He said, you know everybody?
And all the working folks here, if all of them just vote for him, we got to win.
And that's how they got started.
So that, that seat was there, but it was just sitting still, you know.
And then that's when I started.
I made a point that go back there late on us that I followed through advice.
She said in the every community, every that type person.
And then when I went to other places, you know, I was looking for that type.
I got to Forrest City, that little lady over there.
I can't think of any names anymore.
She had a store, a little store.
And I walked into her and introduced myself.
And that said that I, what I was doing, and I'm trying to encourage people to vote.
And we are running for Kennedy.
She said, I ran two years ago, but I didn't have no vote.
And this folks, she said, I love to work with you.
And she took off your car.
We took off.
So I don't know if she said, well, I'm getting kind of old now.
But my son just finished college on a pint block.
And I'm not talking about running.
But she was able to rat a those type meeting.
And a few years later, after I'd gone, I learned there's a lot more elected.
Before elected folks started, you know, that car, that car all, and it took off.
And I said, well, by then, when I went back through there and learned something.
And I met her.
I met her.
He's an attorney in Leroy.
What's her name?
I chat up with him.
And he said, you have some good things been going on.
And he worked with, they had a health clinic in Forrest City.
And Bill Clinton appointed him on a stand as a federal judge.
What's that guy's name?
Oh, shoot.
It had to come to me.
And he said, oh, it's a lot of good things that's gone on in East Austin.
I mean, East Arkansas.
And then that's where I stayed in that circle until I left.
Because I didn't want to just be a combination.
Because I thought we had gotten past that a little bit.
Before we turned to some of the reasons that you departed in 65, I moved Atlanta.
What was your mood?
What was your sense of relative games?
What was your challenges not met?
How are you feeling about your work out there in those after some false history on them?
Well, you know, I feel good because I have a personality of incredible tolerance.
And when I go out to do things and folks don't participate or we don't get it done,
I don't get disgusted.
I get mad.
I just say to myself, well, we can't win them all.
And I've always been that type of person.
But I also learn is my personality has helped me a lot.
You know, I don't get mad with folks.
I don't pick and choose.
I can take it.
You don't.
I mean, it doesn't bother me at all.
And so I don't see it as a failure.
You know, sometimes I said, you know, I wish we could have done or could have gotten a bigger role of folks participated.
But it doesn't bother me at all.
And I'm very realistic about things.
I have never put my eyes on when I look at doing things.
I work at a hard and very diligent.
But if it's, if 15 people step up and really work at getting it done,
some folks are just like in church.
Some folks, you can get a lot done.
But some folks think if you can't get 75 people to help you, that's a failure.
I say, no, 75, 75 people will be a problem for you.
So let's get a small group that's got high energy ready to go.
And that's where I've always worked.
And I think because I was, I could recruit people and identify.
Folks took off and did a lot of things.
I remember I was in Georgia.
And I went to a lot of what was a town called.
And I went down to this little town.
And this was a, yeah,
and I went to this town.
And there was a little town where they had a little factory and a left town
and air about unemployed.
And so when I got there, I said, well,
I went with this school teacher.
She's a very prominent woman in their neighborhood.
And I said, well, I'd like to have a little meeting.
She said, I can get the people to come out.
And when they all came out,
to the meters of bank media,
there was a big warehouse sitting there.
I thought, well, that's a big warehouse and they shut down.
So I said, well, what would, what did it, what did it,
thoughts about what you would like to do?
Everybody in this building had these big thoughts of like building a
signifier store, which high rise buildings is all kind of wild stuff.
And I said, can I make a comment on something I see with my eyes?
This is your plan.
I said, if a plant comes here and you'll get a chance to go to work,
I said, I see so many babies, so many kids.
I don't think nobody's room could go to work.
And so they all died laughing.
And I said, Mr. Joe, you're right.
You got that for you to go to work.
You got to elsewhere to leave.
You got five or six kids.
I said, one thing I would suggest is
you all need to consider a nursery to keep kids.
I mean, that tile was sagittory with little kids.
I mean, everybody had five kids like 10.
And this lady said, my brother,
and that big warehouse, that was her brother's warehouse.
She said, my brother got a big warehouse.
And she said, he is such a hustler.
He ain't gonna let you have that.
I said, what kind of hustling?
She said, he's a big time gamma.
And he love money.
He ain't gonna do nothing.
So I said, let me, I like to meet him.
She said, I call him.
So he came to the meeting.
Hit the five, you know, kind of guy.
Maybe six days.
I said, sir,
in order for this town to even think about going to work,
or that's what other works in the middle of town,
but they couldn't go to work in the wet, take care of you.
I said, we,
if we could build a nursing home here,
for these kids to be taken care of,
I think a lot of these, most of these women here could find work.
He said, you think so? I think so.
See, I don't already talk to this, this, this, this,
this, um, big,
uh, army, uh,
uh,
Robert someplace.
It's a big, big military.
They were hiring a lot of people and, uh, there's common labor.
So I said, and that's your warehouse.
He said, yeah.
He said, I said,
at big warehouse could be turned into, I said, what you gonna do?
He said, I own it. I own it. I own it.
I'm not with it.
I said, we could turn that big warehouse into, uh,
one heck of a nursery.
And these folks would have a place to keep these kids
and they could go to work.
He said, well, Mr. Jones,
if you could get,
get them, get them, get them renewed,
they need a lot of work on it.
I give it to the group.
I was not giving it to the group, I was saying.
I said, ladies,
we got, we got work to do.
This is it.
What we got to do, I said, me and all of y'all going over there,
we got a chair at a whole house out,
tell all that wall down,
and we got to put all that board out there on the street,
and we got to call the city to tell them to pick it up.
And I said, y'all ready to do that?
You got to make us do that.
Yes, ma'am.
All of you every woman is out.
They showed up.
And the thing that was so beautiful about this,
when the,
there's a big lumber company in this next town.
And this guy had taken some lumber somewhere,
and he came by,
and all he went,
bop, bop, bop.
And that guy, he said, come here, sir.
You, you, you know what I mean?
I see.
What, are you in charge of this?
I said, yes, sir.
I told a woman,
we want to turn on this place,
riffle on inside,
we got to turn into a nursery.
All the women, all these babies,
can go to work.
And guy said, down there, at the,
he said, you know, he said down there,
at the, at the,
at the,
some robber,
but that's a big,
a, a, a, Navy,
the Navy base or something.
He said, man,
there were a lot of heavy women coming in,
because they, they way short.
He said, you got in the mine,
I said no.
We just, just,
sweating blood.
He said, let me go talk to my boss,
one of robbers,
that's the name of the plane.
Yeah, that's the name of the plane.
This, this guy went down there,
and he was about,
I was there, he came back.
He, he said, you know what?
I got some good news.
He said, if the women got to do all that building,
he told him to say, all that lump out there,
he says, been Lorraine on,
but it's still good.
You, you, you take it up there.
Man, the women built that thing,
and the guy who owned it,
he came up there, he said,
man, are you God, sir?
Are you a Jesus Christ?
Are you mad?
You can't tell the women to do all that work.
I thought they'd do it for themselves.
And we got this huge man,
that thing, that thing,
about two block, three blocks inside.
And so there's one lady who said,
can't you get federal money?
I said, let me tell you about that.
No, you don't want that.
If we get federal money for this,
the federal government
make you push square feet per child,
you won't get a third of them kissing that bill.
But if you private like you are,
you own it, you can stack them in like,
like, sawdings.
And all of y'all that's not working,
don't get a job,
you come down here,
and y'all become the group
that take care of these babies,
and all of y'all that get a job,
y'all start getting a few dollars
for taking care of these kids.
Just like that bad thing,
just took off.
Just took off.
And low after, well,
I would get a little car from folks
and it's much all well.
And we were love to see you come back
and visit them.
That's been years ago.
You know what I mean?
It's always just, you know,
just kind of been a little gifted on that side,
just seeing things and just,
and believe that folks can do it pretty good themselves.
You know.
Let's talk a little bit as we kind of look towards our,
our last section of the bill.
To talk about some of the reasons,
some of the things were happening,
in the SNCC nationally,
how they were liberated in Arkansas,
some things have worked up,
and then how you made your transition over.
We talked earlier about in 64,
the directorship passes formally,
your hands,
and where other whites had come in,
and we're coming in in that time.
So I think the SNCC,
excuse me,
the SNCC staff,
6465-ish in Arkansas,
and we're living about eight people,
four times,
four staffers,
and four black, four white.
The tensions are becoming a little more closely felt,
on the racial leadership of the organization.
The West Gen 65,
they're pretty hot summer nationally,
first riots and all.
The whole question of the integration as model
is now being challenged by lots of folks.
Things aren't, especially, you know,
we talked about the economic difficulties of moving on economic front.
It's just getting, you know, like you said earlier,
some people's vision went to public accommodation,
but actually you say,
you're getting what then,
how do you finally get the economic justice issue on the panel?
So with all that,
it's kind of pretty good.
I'm interested in your perspective on
the growth of your life through that 6465 period,
how those questions played out inside your life,
SNCC in Arkansas,
and how you,
the circumstances that led to your move to move away.
Well, you know, my moving away
and is was,
what I saw,
and what I felt was,
the resources and the use of people
was jointed,
and a lot of the folks who had that energy early
was beginning to drift towards going to work to make a living.
People getting older,
the SNCC group was young and high energy and educated,
and this whole movement was a fun thing.
And a lot of folks was not recognizing,
we get older,
we'll become infamilif folks,
resources of Dwellin,
and that was a natural thing to me.
But a lot of the white kids who have come down
wanted that to be a lifetime situation,
but what we were dealing with was not lifetime.
A lot of the kids that we had worked with
and we saw do wonderful things and SNCC and all of that,
they too had hit college level and gone on.
And when me and my wife,
and I said this to Bill Hansen,
all the men, look guys,
this,
we have done a pretty good job.
And we are going to run it
if we keep stretching it and stretching it
and we ain't doing nothing.
There's no means of income.
And that's when folks start peeling off
because I think the black panthers
and the Stokely Carmichael and all that,
they saw that movement drill into
and they were trying to rebuild
them some new things
and get it going since this is kind of ended.
And then I think to me,
I think SNCC sort of went as far
as its capabilities.
And we had to recognize that we got older
and needed jobs to support families.
And we had seen placky elected officials come in
and I thought that was very successful.
But that will a lot of folks.
And you don't that steal people
who think we still should be doing that know.
It's not the same that it's changed,
people change.
Now, yeah, they are conditions all around.
But it does not fit,
I don't think it's fit a SNCC type of activity
that we were doing.
I think we did pretty good fuel and folks growth.
But I don't think we could be a lifetime instrument for that.
You were Atlanta,
but I'm sure a trap on quite a bit first time.
But 66 in the spring,
John Lewis is out that it's SNCC
and it's a farm like what comes in.
And one last thing I want to ask about
maybe two things left behind
or things will happen in Arkansas
or you're now in these coasts.
One is Worth Long is,
feels compelled to basically make a statement,
challenging the abandonment of the integration of model.
It still becomes, I've actually come to Arkansas
and have things to say about Worth Long.
So I mentioned if you had a,
at the time you were one way away,
I don't know if you had to watch that at that time.
But the other thing is the emergence in Arkansas
and Little Ocky,
like Bobby Brown and the Blackheap United
and that bumped up against that at all.
I didn't bump into it,
but I heard about it and knew it was taking place.
I think the way I perceive that was,
that was going to be a very small faction
and it was going to be very satisfying to Brown
and it was going to be very satisfying to Stokely Carmichael.
But I don't think they were focusing on anything
that was going to be helpful to people.
They were the only one way trip
and they were eager going on it.
Both of those guys always way back in the early days of Snick
want to be the top gun,
but they didn't have an audience.
That's what that is and that's nothing else.
I remember a long time ago,
Stokely Carmichael was trying to carve
around him a group because he wanted to be the next Malcolm X.
That's all that was.
He wasn't focused on benefits of trying to make
a situation better and different.
He just wanted that stock in his hat.
And I never was interested in that.
I think you have to try to make a difference
because the best you can,
but to go out down your own
and carve you out of a little spot,
I think that's to me that's a waste of time.
And it's not going anywhere.
It gets you a lot of media and all that stuff.
There's nothing else I don't think.
I was in tune and knew about all that,
but you know that was anything.
I was with the sharecroppers.
One of the things that I had to deal with
is that was small farmer stuff.
You always had guys who wanted to go attack
the white man, attack FHA and take their money
and just go find all the black farmers
and just throw all the money out there to them.
I said, well guys, that's wasteful thinking.
Excuse us. I'm sorry.
They don't do it.
I'll tell that to you in real.
John, do we jump on it?
We're all.
Okay. All right.
Okay. Let me ask you a couple of things here as we wander down.
One telling important story about the tensions inside
say that you'll work at sharecroppers,
and people have different ideas about how to go at these problems.
With the sharecroppers,
they're folks who feel they deserve being paid a lot of money.
No identification, what fault, but just to do it.
What my assignment was at sharecroppers
was to go identify in Virginia, Georgia,
Florida, South Carolina, small farmers.
And I did not deal with the inside of that mechanism.
I told them, I think there are some opportunities for them to
sell that product and make some of my festinene I worked on.
And I worked with national change stores and the big change stores.
And I learned in that circle,
most of the stores was looking for black farmers, small farmers product.
Closer, fresher, a lot cheaper because of the distance.
And that worked fine.
That was kind of easy.
But what had some on black is they were talking about the money,
the big farmers making, which was not always true.
And shipping it all into the country,
you need a lot of volume.
And they weren't looking over the fact that I got five acres of tomatoes
that I can harvest four times.
And I can send it right here to Crocus and Crocus by,
which is an excellent marketing strategy.
They were looking past that.
And that's the kind of stuff I worked with.
And then they dealt well.
And some of them ended,
but that was because the older population who was farming,
children didn't want to farm and headed to New York.
But this time it closed that price of down.
And some folks don't recognize that.
And you have to be straight with them.
You have nobody to run the farm anymore.
Don't sell your property.
And please don't sell it because in five or ten years,
right here is probably going to be the home of condos.
So you make plenty of money selling it.
So that's the side I've worked on trying to get to the make money.
You mentioned earlier on that,
talking about yourself and how you could go through this experience.
You said you have a realist.
You have kind of a measured sense of the numbers.
Being a realist, did you ever have reason to think that,
you know, looked at it in some ways,
the progress is much slower than we all would like on some of the basic economic questions.
And maybe there's another way to do this.
Maybe institutional racism,
those kinds of built-in headways.
That maybe the integrationist model we had in mind
isn't quite the right model.
Anyway, just any second.
No, I, my thinking was in the mouth,
I never did see it like a lot of the guys did,
that the integration thing was the mouth to go with.
What I did, say though,
is a lot of the white kids who came in and played roles,
I would look very closely at some of them did have very, very good contacts,
parents in big circle, wealthy.
And what I, what I,
wrote in on,
give us some contacts in the Northeast Ohio,
where we can possibly do some things,
do some things,
because some of the folks in the movement
saw when the whites came in,
they thought they saw money
and money to be brought and put in the pot.
I did, I always saw them as potential great contacts
to make better outlets.
For an example,
I, you know, I can saw one of the different kids,
I said, look, we got some,
we got these kids, pretty smart.
Why don't you, like we had some kids in Boston, New York, and DC,
why don't we go to these kids that's pretty smart
and looking to college,
do you in your circle have contact with schools
that we might get scholarship,
that's how I, I, I, I use them.
I never had this dream to heaven,
like a lot of people did.
And I think it, I think my background helped me stay grounded.
You know, my, my,
my parents did well in farming,
but I sold a grind in it,
and I, you know,
so we didn't have this big,
this is a big,
trees of trillion dollar,
trees of dollar falling out of sky.
And, but I think that helped me in grounded.
And I think some of the movement people
didn't have that kind of grounded background
and a lot of that stuff with theory,
you know, what should be a do,
there should be a,
and you know, and sometimes those theories were dependent
on the government doing a whole lot of stuff.
And, and, but the folks you were working with
weren't ready for that,
that, that, that level of stuff.
So, that, that's how I,
and, and I think in terms of slow things,
yeah, I saw slow development.
I saw a lot of things didn't happen.
I, I saw things like,
if it's to try and get,
more nurses and blacks and nursing,
smaller hospitals and smaller towns
and trying to recruit doctors to come in
and, and, and, and those areas and spend time,
that didn't happen.
I was hoping that kind of stuff,
what, what, what have made huge ditch
because you take,
east, east, I can saw,
and you're looking at four-go-an-all-way,
a little rock,
a lot of Memphis,
to the big cities,
and, and, and, and I looked at that,
but that didn't fly.
But when it didn't fly,
it wasn't something that brought me down, you know.
It, uh, oh.
I'm a boss, dude.
I, I guess,
my, my, my, my,
my, my, my,
I saw a lot of growth in people.
I saw a lot of growth in young folks
who excelled and went on.
I think some people see that
because they did well and moved on
was disappointment as opposed to
staying, whether or not
that's just that geographical change
and, and you can't blame people for that.
I felt, I feel real good,
years later,
that I did pretty good,
with putting people together,
with, on the market in,
and small farmers.
I think I, uh,
feel good about,
when I left,
when I left SNCC,
I stayed in, in the rural kind of,
area,
still working on a behalf of people.
And if you look at my resume,
every job I've had,
put me in touch with,
working with a lot of people,
and that's been the joy of my life.
Just, just love that.
Don't, don't, don't, don't.
Probably could have been several other things.
I, I wish
the 50,000, like farmers,
we had identified,
in the east and the south,
and the far south,
could have been, um,
given some payment toward,
the, uh, the government
not allowing them to borrow
money and all of that.
Uh, but,
a lot of those folks,
when a decision was made to recognize them,
95% of those folks
was dead and gone.
And that level is,
who should have been a beneficiary.
And now, the sons and the daughters of those folks
are in Chicago,
in Detroit,
and everywhere else.
Um,
and if there is, uh,
a, um,
a little bit of a comment
about, uh,
compensation,
given,
it needs to be very
careful and done.
I would not
be real excited about
Jundo in Chicago now,
is 37 years old,
and does not even know
who was Grand Dad of War
that farmed
75 years ago.
I, I don't think,
you know, that,
that compensate
who did the hard work.
But, but, but, but,
but I've been very pleased with, uh,
the direction I went in life,
uh, I've all,
I've pretty much been
close to agriculture,
small town,
and that, that,
all my life is,
which is what I love going.
Yeah.
Mr. Jones,
it's really been an honor,
and a great privilege.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
That you came on.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress,
and the Smithsonian National
Museum of African-American
History and Culture.